britt hume is our senior uh political
analyst and he joins us now brit um you
know i know some people call it
exaggerating
but when does it go to the point where
it's just a straight up lie
well i think the thing we have to be
concerned about lawrence is that in
politics and in the news media there's
always been a tendency to state things
as dramatically as possible that makes
uh the charges against your opponents in
politics more effective we people think
and it also makes a news story more
interesting and compelling if you can if
you can state it in as dramatic terms as
possible in normal times
that's sort of how things go there's
nothing particular to worry about these
are not normal times however uh we're
living in a particularly tense age the
country is deeply divided we're in the
midst of this pandemic and and what we
need is people to calm down the bitter
divisions that we see in this country
are exacerbated
by this tendency to ex exaggerate and
and to do so grossly i mean uh
washington post the other day had a
headline about uh corona the
omicron outbreak in the south he's
saying it's going to be a firestorm
firestorms kill people what we seem to
know about omicron so far is
that it's not particularly deadly if
it's deadly at all
so that's the kind of overstatement i'm
talking about but it has a lot of people
really frightened tense on edge and of
course donald trump didn't help this
with his with his wild uh claims about
the theft of the 2020 election by a
voter fraud on election day so this is
the atmosphere we're living in benny
thompson of the of the january 6
committee saying we came critically
close to losing our democracy one of
those sound bites that you played same
thing we weren't close to losing our
democracy it was a cockamamie scheme by
trump that was bound to fail and did
um so that's where we are i think and
it's it's a problem in this age brit
it's one thing if it was just one
situation but this seems to be a pattern
of behavior and if
you allow me i think it started with
russia it was just complete misses of
information they took it as fact used to
spy on a political campaign then you got
them shutting down the country over
misinformation then you got them with
written house
you got them with oh yeah we were never
afforded to fund the police and we've
seen crime raging all across the country
got sound bites for days of them saying
they wanted to fund the police the
border is completely closed yet we see
people trotting around the border
dropping kids as if they're amazon
packages i mean it's just lie after lie
after lie and we're just supposed to
just gloss over it
well what's what part of what's
happening here i think lawrence as you
suggest is that you know a lot of things
that get said may have a kernel of truth
in them but by the time they've been
hyped to the extent that they've been
hyped they turn into falsehoods i mean
look what's happening in chicago with
the teachers unions right now i suspect
that a lot of those teachers out there
sincerely believe that they are really
in danger from the new uh
the new omicron wave
well the science doesn't support that
public health authorities don't seem to
support that but they're imbued with
this and look what they're doing now you
can make the argument as some have that
they're just trying to get out of work
and maybe many of them are on the other
hand i think that people sincerely
believe this because they're too damn
much information and a lot of it comes
from political charges and media hype
yeah and they don't care about the truth
uh brit you're old school guy you've
been there you're a seasoned guy you've
been around the block
a couple times or so
um is this new to you
well
the habit of exaggeration is not new
it's been part of politics and media for
as long as i can remember
what's new is that it is happening in a
moment of particular tension and
division in the country and in the
middle of this of this pandemic which we
badly needed to understand correctly
from the start and to see in perspective
from the start and the consequence of
not doing that has been all the damage
that's now being acknowledged by public
health authorities to children and to
countless other people who are harmed by
these buddies these heavy-handed and it
seems like in nearly all cases
unnecessary lockdown school closures and
the rest of it that's what's worrisome
to me yeah you're exactly right the harm
that is being done by all these lies
that they're telling britta hume thanks
so much for stopping by primetime thank
you thank you lauren